[Musique] il a été élu maire à 26 ans député à 29
mon invité est un jeune homme pressé
qui ne s'embarrasse pas forcément des
manières en politique son ambition
changer le logiciel de la [Musique]
droite bonjour pierreenri Dumont bonjour
Alors qui sont de nous regarder ou de
nous écouter en podcast vont me maudir
parce qu'on va commencer cette émission
par une chanson qui a tendance à rester
dans la tête toute la journée vous voyez
de quoi je parle VO très bien bon c'est
le fameux lipd des jeunes de l'UMP qui a
été lancé fin 2009 et vous allez sans
doute reconnaître l'un des [Musique]
interprètes alors on a reconnu Rach ramaade mais
on s'est permis de faire aussi un arrêt sur image
sur un un jeune homme l'un des interprètes on le
voit ici en train de taper sur un un jump B vous
le reconnaissez oui bah c'était mes années
militantes c'est vrai que ça reste un beau
souvenir bon il y a eu un un BAT de buzz sur sur
mais non non au final donc beaucoup de gens s'en
sont un peu moqués on va dire ouis mais mais au
final on a pris vraiment énormément de plaisir
à le tourner il y a eu un décalage dans dans la
diffusion ça doit être diffusé à l'issue à la fin
des 3 jours du campus des jeunes où on partait la
dans le train donc c'est le train aller ça a été
diffusé 3 mois après au moment des fêtes de Noël
entre-temps la crise financière est arrivée donc
évidemment le contexte était pas le même clim
avait changé mais honnêtement c'est aussi un
symbole des années jeune pop qui on est un grand
mouvement jeune 30000 jeunes alors à l'époque vous
étiez vous aviez 22 ans vous aviez déjà des
responsabilités au sein du mouvement des des
Jeunes Populaires de l'UMP vous avez pris votre
carte à l'UMP à 17 ans qu'est-ce qui peut motiver
un adolescent comme ça à s'engager dans un parti
politique aussi jeune euh une personnalité c'est C
Nicolas Sarkozi son dynamisme moi je me souviens
de de jou que je regardais à la télévision chez
moi quand j'étais encore un peu plus jeune mais
quand Taric Ramadan quand Jean Marie Le Pen où
il écrasé le match et c'était ce dynamisme cette
volonté cette envie de changement de faire qui qui
moi m'a m'a vraiment appé et c'est pour ça que
j'ai pris ma carte c'est pour Nicolas Sarkozi
alors il y a aussi il y avait un Terrero familial
qui était propice on va dire vos parents vous ont
un peu fait baigner dans la la culture gouliste
RPR c'est ça oui mais mes parents étaient tous
les deux des des adhérents RPR ils sont pour
certains ont été candidats à des élections on
voit là la photo de mon père qui était Candat
je crois c une cantonnale en 82 ou 83 dans un
canton de de Calais et donc on l'appelait lege
valesa à l'époque c'est vratit côté Val avec la
mouache et et donc du coup oui c'était un terro
RPR militant vous allez même aux réunion des du
RPR à 7 ans c'était oui c'était l'anecdote mais
avec le t-shirt les jeunes avec Chirac voilà lors
des soirées électorales c la soirée électorale
de 95 du coup d'élection présidentielle de 95 et
en effet je me suis retrouvé avec un t-irt les
jeunes avec Chirac dans un un garage de caléis
qui avait été loué à l'occasion pour faire une
permanence de campagne locale pour les élections
présidentielles donc oui j'ai baigné dans un
terro qui est un terro RPR de droite euh mais
par des parents qui voilà incarneent aussi cette
envie de travailler de toujours faire plus qui ont
créé leurs propres entreprises qui sont partis
quasiment de rien et qui ont réussi donc c'est
aussi cette tradition cette histoire familiale
que je cherche à à honorer par mon engagement
tique et alors sur le papier vous avez un parcours
qui est assez classique he il y a les Jeunes Pop
on l'a vu il y a eu Science Po Paris vous avez ét
aussi collaborateur d'un d'un député à l'Assemblée
mais vous dites que votre parcours il est devenu
aujourd'hui une exception pour les gens issus des
classes moyennes comme vous et vous en faites
d'ailleurs un combat politique qui est un peu
au cœur de votre engagement oui c'est vraiment
l'angle que je prends et la ligne directrice
que je me fixe pour mon engagement politique
c'est faire en sorte que n'importe quel gamin
en particulier chez moi dans dans le Pas de Calais
à Calais dans le calaisy la ruralité qui a envie
de faire des études supérieures quel que soit ces
des études supérieures soit en mesure de pouvoir
le faire il faut pas que l'argent le milieu
familial soit un frein il demande évidemment
être bien orienté mais il y a aussi une question
de moyens il y a une question de moyens public les
lycées chez moi il forment pas à rentrer dans des
classes prépa il forment pas à passer des concours
ou quand vous avez dit au lycé que vous vouliez
faire Sciences Po on a compris la fac de science
polique politique l'école à Paris exactement et
et donc du coup moi ce que je dis c'est que il
faut déjà que tous les lycées forment aux mêmes
choses c'estàd pas simplement avoir le bac mais
préparer les études supérieures mais audelà de ça
il faut que là où on peut aider c'est ce que j'ai
fait par exemple dans ma commune de marquencalisie
quand j'étais maire et on a continué à mettre en
place ce système quand un gamin de la ville veut
aller faire des études en Erasmus à l'étranger que
les parents peuvent pas payer on peut donner
des bourses qui vont jusqu'à 10000 € on aide
le permis de conduire on aide à passer le BAFA
c'està dire que en gros on donne les moyens aux
jeunes de se réaliser alors il y a une nouvelle
étape dans votre engagement en politique franchi
en 2014 vous vous êtes présenté à la mairie de
Marc près de de Calais c'est une ville qui est
historiquement ancrée à gauche vos parents ont été
convaincu que vous alliez perdre et vous pendant
toute la campagne vous avez martelé que vous étiez
le candidat le plus compétent à 26 ans il faut un
sacré culot pour faire ça parce que vous avez été
élu hein oui c'est j'aiété élu on voit là c'est le
conseil municipal d'installation en en mars 2014
j'ai été élu parce que les habitants de la ville
m'ont fait confiance voilà c'est en effet une
ville qui était historiquement de gauche mais dire
à 26 ans c'est moi le plus compétent il a pas une
part non c'est factuel c'est-à-dire que j'étais
face à des personnes don qui avaient fait le
travail de la ville la ville c'est bien développé
mais qui commençait à stagner se transformer
progressivement en cité d'ortoir on pour être très
clair moi j'éis arrivé avec un autre programme
et puis en effet il faut quand même évidemment un
peu un peu de culot pour pour arriver débarquer
comme ça moi c'est ma ville natale c'est là où
j'ai grandi je faisais des allers-retours parce
que forcément je travaillais à Paris la semaine
mais mais c'était vraiment une belle aventure
et honnêtement le mandat de maire est le plus
beau mandat qu'on peut exercer dans la République
française c'est là où on est vraiment au prisme
avec les besoins du territoire c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que quand j'ai été élu député en 2017 j'ai
gardé mon mandat de conseiller municipal et j'ai
abandonné le mandat de conseiller départemental
alors Duculot vous en avez eu aussi lors de vos
premiers vœux en tant que maire de Marc vous avez
convié tous les élus de l'agglomération et et
vous leur êtes rentré dedans assez violemment
on voit les articles de presse de l'époque ça a
fait un peu la une des journaux localement c'est
votre style en politique on on cogne d'abord
on discute après éventuellement c'est ça c'est
ma ma ma devise en politique c'est d'abord
on gueule et après on discute et là et là
c'est efficaceah c'est c'est plutôt efficace
parce que je vais vous dire ce qui s'est passé
après la cérémonie des vœux j'ai visé trois euh
trois trois cibles la première cible c'était le
président d'agglomération de l'époque qui avait
augmenté les impôts des ménages alors que moi
dans ma ville je l'ai diminué donc les habitants
benah disaient attendez Monsieur le Maire on voit
pas la différence parce que pour eux ça revient
au même et d'ailleurs on s'est aperçu après des
rapports après des discussions avec les élu qu'il
y avait en effet de la cavalerie budgétaire donc
j'ai soulevé un lièvre à ce moment-là qui a coûté
sa place au président d'agglomération on est arriv
arrivé au point où ne pouvait plus investir tous
les investissements dans l'agglomération avaient
été gelés à cause de l'explosion de dépenses de
fonctionnement sur la question de de l'État et de
la ville de calis à côté moi j'avais mis en doute
la création du camp julferry qui a mené quelques
mois plus tard à la création de la fameuse jungle
à Calais qui é à la frontière entre Calais et
Marc 10000 personnes dans un bidonville j'avais
alerté sur le fait que ça allait devenir ce que
c'est devenu et donc j'ai pas forcément tort
dans ce que j'avais dit malheureusement al on
a vu vos premiers vœux assez musclés en tant que
maire en 2017 à peine élu député vous avez aussi
un peu secouer le le cocotier mais cette fois
dans votre propre parti avec l'ambition bah de
prendre la place des anciens on va dire votre mot
d'ordre c'est un peu place aux jeunes c'est c'est
c'est une forme de dégagisme presque non c'est
pas place aux jeunes c'est de dire que tout le
monde doit trouver sa place et que c'est pas parce
qu'on vient d'être élu que qu'on qu'on débarque un
peu de territoire où il y avait jamais eu d'élus
auparavant ou très très peu que ce soit moi dans
pascalé que ce soit Aurélien dans l'autre que ce
soit d'autre que que ce qu'on dit est pas moins
vrai que ceux qui sont présents depuis longtemps
donc l'enjeu c'est maintenant en effet maintenant
qu'on a un peu vieilli tous pris un peu plus
d'assurance encore c'est de pouvoir expliquer que
bah le logiciel de la droite doit changer qu'on
doit pas parler simplement aux classes moyenne
supérieurure et aux personnesraité mais que on
a tout un un terau de gens de droite qui sont
nous nos électeurs dans nos circonscriptions qui
sont des gens qui croient dans la valeur travail
qui se lèvent tout le matin pour travailler qui
gagnent pas des mers des C qui roulent pas sur
l'or et qui ont besoin de propositions de texte
de la droite donc c'est cette c'est cette idée
là c'est ce projet politique là que vous portez
vous les les jeunes trentenaires parce que vous
formez un petit groupe en fait au sein du
du groupe les républicains euh il y a qui
d'ailleurs dans dans dans ce groupe ah bah il
y a plusieurs personnes c'est principalement
des personnes qu'on connaissait déjà avant de
venir à l'Assemblée nationale parce que c'était
dans les réseaux les terau Jeunes Populaires
à l'époque on en voit certains sur les photos
ça c'est la précédente législature mais euh
c'est fait par bon évidemment Julien di qui
était responsable départemental des Jeunes
de l'INE com moi j'étais dans le pas decalis
on a Aurélien évidemment dans le lotte Yan dans
dans le territoire deà on est un petit groupe
géographiquement on est déjà avec nos bureau côte
à côe depuis le précédent mandat et puis après on
s'entend bien parce que voilà on partage à âge des
territoires qui sont pas des territoire évident
qui ont à peu près les mêmes caractéristiques d'un
point de vue sociologique et puis ce côté un peu
on est on est débarqué de nulle part et on essaye
d'imposer un style peut-être un peu différent mais
on en a besoin aujourd'hui la droite c'est quoi
c'est moins de 5 % l'élection présidentiell donc
soit on décide de continuer comme on fait depuis
15 ans à savoir dire toujours les mêmes choses et
se retrouver dans une situation où on nintéresse
plus personne soit on essaie de légèrement changer
le logiciel faire comprendre que la population
et les Françaises et les Français ont évolué et
que la droite doit pouvoir toujours en gardant ses
valeurs chevillé au corps proposer autre chose que
ce qu'elle a pu proposer je pense que le paroxisme
c'était la question de la réforme des retraites
ou la réforme des retraites on avait vraiment
un axe sur la question des des carrière longue
pourquoi c'est pas pour embêter le parti pour
embêter la droite c'est simplement pour dire
que nous on va pas commencer par pénaliser ceux
qui ont commencé en apprentissage ceux qui ont
commencé le plus tôt et pas pénaliser les cadres
et les cadres sub ceux qui ont fait les plus
longues études tant mieux pour eux qui gagne le
plus tant mieux pour eux mais on peut pas avoir un
de poid de mesure donc c'est cette idée de renouer
avec les classes populaires qui a fait que dans ce
petit groupe là vous avez tous je crois hein voter
la motion de censure contre le gouverneur contre
le gouvernement à l'occasion de cette réforme
des retraites euh c'est pas très réglot parce
que vous avez pas respecté la consigne qui avait
été adoptée à la majorité au sein de votre groupe
oui mais la Constitution dispose qu'il n'y a pas
demander impératif ouais mais enfin la politique
c'est c'est aussi respecter un collectif respecter
le fait majoritaire oui non mais moi l'engagement
que j'avais pris devant mes devant mes habitants
c'est celui j'avais écrit noir sur blanc lors de
ma campagne électorale moi j'ai respecté mon
engagement pris devant mes électeurs et j'ai
pas pris un engagement devant mon groupe d'abord
les électeurs ensuite le groupe on va passer à
notre quiz à présent le principe est assez simple
je vais vous proposer des phrases et vous allez
devoir les compléter c'est bon pour vous allez
rien de tel qu'une partie de FIFA pour tisser
le lien avec les jeunes et pour se détendre ouais
parce qu'en fait vous à plusieurs reprises vous
avez organisé comme ça des défis vous avez défié
les jeunes de votre circonscription venez défier
votre député à FIFA ça marche vraiment vous arri
à les intéresser à la politique comme ça ça marche
pas ouais alors les intéressé à la politique
oui et non mais en tout cas on peut échanger
sur leur quotidien et donc moi ça me donne des
bit pour comprendre ce qui se passe parce que
jeêtre jeune mais ça fait quand même longtemps
que j'ai pas mis les pieds dans une classe de BTS
et cetera donc c'est aussi le moyen de pouvoir
savoir ce qui se passe échanger de façon plus
plus détendue quand les sénateurs de droite me
qualifient de sale gosse ils ont parfaitement
raison vous êtes un sal gosse vous l'assumez oui
mais je je suis un sal gosse mais parce ils ont
dit ça quand vous avez voulu aligner leur régime
de retraite sur celui des députés c'est ça oui
bah ce qui est normal et je le referai aujourd'hui
bien sûr enfin si je fais trois mandats de députés
est-ce qu'il y en aura un 4e c'est pas à moi de
le décider vous aviez pris un engagement en 2017
vous aviez dit deux ou trois mandats maximum
ouais ou oui c'est c'est vrai non parce que
l'envie de faire autre chose est toujours toujours
présente euh député ça prend du temps ça prend du
temps sur la vie privé familial sincèrement
et je vais arriver à un âge après déjà à la
fin de ce mandat j'aurais passé les je procherai
les 40 ans ou là et donc non non mais mais mais
non mais voilà enfin je suis pas marié j'ai
pas d'enfants j'ai aussi besoin de construire
une vie privée familialeut et donc c'est une
question non mais c'est une question qui moi
me tarode mais tarode aussi beaucoup de députés
de ma génération parce que quand on est arrivé
à l'Assemblée on était pas marié sans enfants
contrairement à des députés d'autres législatures
qui eux venaient en fin ou en milieu de parcours
politique où ils avaient déjà construit une vie
familiale avant merci beaucoup Pierre-Henri du
monde d'êt venu dans la politique et [Musique]
moi [Musique]